J is with us in Texas starting off this
hour
hi J how are you hey Dave I've been
listening to you since I was 15 and now
my late 20s so huge fan and wanted to
kind of seek your advice well honor Tom
how can I help ya everyone including my
family members church friends and
financial advisers are saying my wife
and I should buy a house but we just
felt like it's best to continue renting
at this point and we just kind of wanted
to kind of see your take on this well I
mean to start with no one gets a vote
except you and your wife
unless you're given less you give them a
vote but I wouldn't give people a vote
if I don't agree with their vote and so
you know if you have a financial advisor
that's advising you to do something
financially that you don't think is wise
then you have the wrong financial
advisor if your mom and dad have
boundaries issues then they have
boundaries issues if your friends can't
keep their mouths shut then you know
they're just got to learn which topics
you allow people to talk about but I
don't let people tell me what I'm going
to do with my money and you're a grown
man you don't either now is it let's
look at the situation and I'll give you
an opinion but even I don't get a vote
unless you give me one you know you call
TAS that's kind of giving me a vote but
still you and your wife have to talk
about it and go in light of this this is
what we would consider you know I don't
recommend nor do I believe you should
rent your whole life right right right
so why are you delaying buying what's
your what's your wisdom on that so I
mean larb our belief is that you know
like you said cash is king and you know
I lived on the simple mentality if I
don't have the money for it and I can't
afford it and you know for me I've
really wanted to put you know hundred
percent down okay so you're saving to
buy a house for cash and how long have
you been doing that we've been doing
about for two years or so okay and how
long is it going to take you probably
three years
or depending on three yeah three more
years okay it would be 31 and you would
pay cash for a house is that what I
understood yes how big a house is this
um 700 K 600k okay how much of you guys
save now
well I currently have a hundred K safe
for the house itself but my annual
income will change significantly in two
years okay so you're going through a
career shift or what I finished my
training I'm in the medical profession
and I'll have a real paint job in two
years very in two years okay so you're
like in residency or something like that
right okay cool
all right well so you have a very clear
vision for your life a $700,000 paid for
house at 31 years old after you get out
of residency yes and people's problem
with that is what they think you oughta
buy something now while you're in
residency we technically have enough
like down paying money for a 20% down
payment for our small of the lesser
house and and nothing come right now for
us not between us for a 15 year mortgage
now what's your household income it's
currently 150 K then what city do you
live in and we live in Houston Texas
will you remain there after your
residency yeah that's the plan okay so
you have a hundred now how quickly will
you have two hundred two hundred well so
whenever I finished my rinsing whenever
I get my first paycheck I should have
another hundred okay and when was when
do you finish residency two more years
you had two more years okay so you're
gonna make five hundred thousand dollars
in savings in one year that should drain
I mean the annual income should be five
hundred and my wife makes money too okay
I I don't dislike your plan when I was
fishing for us kind of thinking about
buying something as small something on
the interim and paying cash for it still
you know like if you could buy something
that's
I was asking about 200 if you could buy
something for two it's probably tough to
find something for a hundred in Houston
that's much of anything you probably
find it but it might not be what you
want I mean you may you may rather rent
than that and so do I think you are
foolish for renting for three years
while you finish residency and your
income goes from fifty thousand a year
to five hundred thousand dollars a year
no I do not and you're paying cash at
thirty-one and if you have an investment
advisor that thinks that you're foolish
and is shaming you for that I would fire
them gotcha I think you're brilliant I
think you're quite the opposite of most
doctors and there are more bloke doctors
than there are broke musicians because
they all think they have a plan and
they're so deeply in debt they can't
breathe in most cases we work with them
all the time
broke doctors are a stereotype in our
world I'm a doctor a translation I have
a lot of payments is what it usually
means so you're quite the opposite not
all doctors are but I'm just saying
there's a reason for the stereotype and
you're quite the opposite of this I'm so
proud of you I I support your plan I
don't think you're irrational you you
might be over here on the edge with me
in the land of extreme but you're also
going to make five hundred thousand
dollars a year living in a $700,000
paid-for house unless you're beating
that plan you probably don't have a
right to say anything to mr. J you know
that's like people going I don't think I
agree with not borrowing money on real
estate well I own about 300 million
dollars worth it I paid cash for so I
don't really care whether you agree or
not you know you don't really get a vote
until you Trump that card right and so
beat that hand and then we'll talk about
your freakin opinion so you know that's
you'd be nice to people but um you just
smile and shake your head I mean we've
all got friends and relatives that do
crazy but stuff I got relatives that
vote wrong but I still love them you
know and so you just have to kind of
think that through and in your case I
would just as dr. Lunt Delon he says dr.
John says don't give them a vote in this
in this instance
and I know you don't understand dad but
this is my plan and I'm gonna stick to
it and I appreciate you I know you love
me and thank you for your input but I'm
I'm this is our plan and we're gonna
stick to it
and I'm really not going to talk to you
about it 73 more times you're not gonna
help me about it and I'd fire the
financial advisor today and get another
one if they're bugging you to go buy
something because they think they got a
doctor on the hook who's going to make
five hundred thousand dollars a year and
they want him giving them a bunch of
money to invest and they make a
commission on instead of worrying about
you having a paid-for house so their
goals don't match up with yours Wow
impressive young guy congratulations doc
you're not gonna be a broke doc that's
very cool